- Well I'm ready to go,
I've eaten my coffee cube.
Wouldn't be ready this
early if I was, a, just, a,
drinkin liquid like some kind a sucker.
- Most days I will have
two cups of coffee a day.
The smell of coffee also
makes me feel better.
- It's really more about
the ritual of drinking,
than the actual drink itself.
- I'm addicted to coffee,
but also I love it,
so I don't really care
that I'm addicted to it.
- We're giving up coffee for a whole week
and trading it out for chewable coffee.
It hurts me to say that.
(laughs)
(funky jazz music)
- They did not look how I
thought they were going to look.
Oh they smell good though.
- If you can see, it's just
a very, that's squishy.
- Aaahhhh.
(laughs)
- This is just candy.
- Oh my God.
(gags)
- Man that flavor really
punches you in the mouth.
- C-, I'm sorry, F.
- I don't wanna do this.
(laughs)
I can't eat one of these every day.
(liquid pours)
- I think knowing what to expect,
the taste isn't as bad
this time, so, yeah.
This week might be alright.
- You know they didn't
taste so bad this morning
and I was pretty okay, so I'm
optimistic about this week.
- No, they still taste bad.
- My room is very cold this morning.
Conveniently, there's a cube here.
On a cold morning, there's
nothing more reassuring
and a nice way to start the day,
then just a nice hot cup of coffee,
but I didn't have that.
(whimpers)
- All I want is a cup of coffee
and I am seriously regretting
agreeing to do this.
- I went into a coffee shop just now,
just to, just to, just
to smell it, you know.
- I will openly admit to cheating.
I gave up on the cubes, I
went straight for the coffee.
I'm just too tired.
- What are you getting?
- Chicken, artichoke.
(laughs)
It's coffee.
- I'm drinking coffee,
but I needed to make it
through today and I wasn't gonna be able
to do it on just those cubes.
- I'm trying to watch
the morning news here.
Normally I'd do this while,
while drinking coffee
but, oh, not today.
- It was a bit of a roller coaster,
but it was really just like
the top of the roller coaster
to the bottom of the drop.
- I always talk about how great it'll be
when we can eat meals in pill form.
It's like, if you're like "wow,
I really like Thanksgiving.
I'm gonna sit home this year
and eat turkey-flavored cotton candy.
Alone.
- Drinking coffee makes me happy and
I'm gonna keep doing it.
Now I sound like a cigarette smoker but...
(laughs)
- I get that if you're
like, super in a bind,
and you need, like, a quick pick-me-up.
I guess that's what these are for.
- Do I get a little coffee?
The joys this brings me can never
be replaced by a damn sugar cube.
- Coffee is a gift, don't fix
what's not broken, ya know.
- I don't necessarily
care for the sweet stuff,
but it's still better than those cubes.
Anything's better than those cubes.
- I'm just eatin a cube.